yeah welcome to this video and this is a
set of two blitz games against chess
aholic from the US he's a spectator what
sure what do you say watcher of the
channels is correct spectator yeah well
he's he knows the channel he he
challenged me to a set of two blitz
games we did this earlier and he did a
pretty good job put up a good fight um
yeah with some transposition we got into
a Sicilian now 10mon of sicilian with
the quick capture on c6 okay try to use
the dark squares here playing 'if I've
and therefore putting his bishop on d3
get sort of in a box of the e4 and ce4
pound so I prevent him to play a 45 and
now I try to use this Bishop on d4 on c5
so once if I for now and it might go to
default at a later stage now you decided
to play this is interesting maybe a F
form yeah okay let's make sure that f4
doesn't happen it looks weak of course
but how is he going to exploit it so a 5
probably am preventing before for the
moment and now at least I get them I get
da foul if he pushes this how to
continue
hmm
maybe I should play will be aid actually
just preventing this it's probably good
how does he play before now it's not
they're not so easy
oh ok not probably did it is easy he
just the Texas he's sick son okay but
this is some just a pawn let's think
about this for a moment if what what are
my active ideas he's not really
threatening to take by the way I could
just play Bishop d7 and basically the
queen is trapped I wonder about the most
like h5 if I can cannot play something
like that twice this zone this is
complete nonsense come on now with the
Queen on a four maybe this is even
viable I think he hidden he needs to
reactor h4 threatens to win a piece h3
it doesn't help I mean completely pledge
for energy form just activating maybe ok
he allowed that ok you can it's not like
I'm winning or something chief or maybe
this is completely idiotic kept pushing
the pawns don't know what I threatened
to take on them on edge free maybe maybe
I do
okay I gained some space also this is so
not not bad at all I'm a bit afraid of
before still takes takes bishop before
you can play a 90 to 1 this is a really
really a pest and g4 is this Dino ok
let's try to keep him busy busy on the
on the King side maybe this is just
weakening and doesn't really help at all
okay yeah this is of course very sharp
also good today okay I can take I can
take on a 3 and 0 ng to this leads to
yeah complete chaos come on let's do
this just now retreating
yeah how to hard to understand this
position
93 is a move where I can give this
chicken on g1 okay I probably need to
need to take this I don't really know
what's going on if i take here I know my
king position looks looks really
dangerous but I'm not 22 rookie can
click email a group g1 them and key at
Queenie to this one I this decide didn't
expect Quinn g5 I thought getting on the
dark squares dark squares okay okay
hmm yeah well he's got the Queen's off
position now is this perfectly alright
even if I lose the porn I've got
brilliant bishops
shoot it's got g one now so that I must
go to see if I of course I want to go to
e5 and then then there's root g one
the other time is the the time is the
biggest problem actually the position is
completely okay even with the porn down
doesn't really matter I can always win
win something back
look fh taking on d5 have pin the sage
bonus now we're going to Queen check we
should before I object as this one
check-check time working group g8 Luke
h8 mate this is the idea I hope this is
winning I mean yeah okay it is winning
I've got this King in a box so this is
actually really strong look h eight
major yeah like reason who yeah he's
playing good playing well okay of course
this age five ish was maybe a bit to
petition ok so this this was the first
game and yeah the second one is coming
up right now